welcome back to New rockstars my name is
Anna vanston and hardcore fans of The
Last of Us game we're thrilled to see
some of the voice and mocap actors
making a return for the HBO show but
there might have been even more cameos
than Yukon today we're going to be
taking a look at all of the noteworthy
cameos in the show and how they got
involved so let's start with cameos that
were heard instead of seen if you
thought the infected clicker sounded
exactly like the game
you would be right voice actors Misty
Lee and Philip kovatz voiced the
clickers in the first game and returned
to voice them in the show as well Lee
did an interview where she talked about
how she helped create the signature
clicker sound for the game saying when
she went into the booth she was shown a
picture of what they were going to look
like and what they did and it was all
experimentation from there she stressed
the importance of embodying the
character's posture and mindset when
trying to find the sound and how the
team wanted to stay away from it
sounding too human but didn't want to
remove the humanity completely she
remembered being given the visual of
tearing your family apart but you can't
stop it chilling when she eventually
came to the clicking noise they knew
they were on the right path and started
messing with variations of that she
found it taught it to kovats and he in
turn taught others she noted the main
difference between voice acting for the
game and voice acting for the show was
that for the game they just recorded all
the sounds ahead of time but for the
show they would be shown the scene at a
super low volume and they would have to
voice over it having to adjust their
sounds to the clicker's movements taking
turns and at times voicing them together
thank you
she admits that while the voice doesn't
hurt to do it does do some damage and
she had to go on vocal rest for several
days following the episode worth it
not bad right sometimes when you love a
show or movie it's not enough to have
seen it you need some merch to
commemorate the occasion and nerd riots
got you covered if the finale of The
Last of Us left you hungry for more pick
up a lunch of us tea available in cream
or black featuring the logo of Todd's
Steakhouse from episode 8 of the series
don't eat there though just don't do
that unless you're a cannibal in which
case Bon Appetit baby if you're stoked
for the upcoming John Wick movie nerd
ride has a whole line of John Wick
shirts to make you feel like you've got
to see it at the high table there's the
Baba yagati a gun Chuck's tea and a t
for the high table itself proclaiming I
have served I will be of service get
them now and you'll be able to wear them
to opening night and then also the next
weekend when you see John Wick chapter
four for the second time and of course
if you're obsessing over the Mandalorian
right now there's a whole line Amanda
merch in the way collection with teas
beanies hats and even stuff for kids to
get your hands on the merch you need
head to nerdyright.shop today join the
riot over at nerd riot.shop another
vocal Cameo was made by co-showrunner
Craig Mason's daughter Jessica Mason who
sang a cover of Depeche Mode's never let
me down again at the end of episode 6.
on HBO's The Last of Us podcast Craig
said he wanted to reintroduce the song
in a female voice to represent Ellie and
that he knew his daughter could nail it
he sent her the song and asked her to do
a slow and haunting cover with a
daughter mourning the loss of her father
in mind and joked that she
unenthusiastically said okay and then
forgot about it until he brought it up a
couple weeks later stressing that it was
for television and to be fair you should
have left with that but it was worth it
as we got this beautiful cover as a
result
lets me down again there's a theory
going around new rock stars that Craig
Mason might have also made a vocal Cameo
as the soldier that shoots Sarah but
that has yet to be officially verified
serving as the perfect Bridge from only
heard to scene we have Laura Bailey who
was Abby in The Last of Us Part Two who
made a sneaky Cameo behind a mask as a
firefly nurse in the finale Billy wasn't
cast in the show until late in the game
where Mason contacted her in the final
days of production wanting to get her in
the show but only having that part
available he says she was completely
game though and actually said it was
even better that she'd be wearing a mask
because then it would be like a Cool
Secret Cameo amazing didn't know however
is that Bailey actually also played one
of the nurses in the first game in
addition to a reporter at the beginning
of the game Life is weird friends
another actor from the game who got to
make a return this time in the original
role of Perry was Jeffrey Pierce voice
actor of Tommy for the games Pierce
admits that he knew his window to play a
live-action version of Tommy closed
about a decade ago but when he knew that
Creator Neil druckman and Mason got the
green light on the show he emailed
directman saying look I'll come carry a
spear and stand in the background and
really just wanted to be a part of the
project and support it in whatever way
he could after initially reading a few
different ways for one particular
character Pierce says they told him that
they weren't ever gonna buy him as a
victim sort of role but that they would
see if there was something else down the
road fast forward two weeks and they
sent him the scripts for Perry saying
they found the perfect thing he was
overjoyed and happily accepted the role
and they said don't cut your hair we'll
see you in January February definitely
beats caring experience standing in the
background now there's only one actor
who returned to reprise their original
role and that is Merle Dandridge as
Marlene Dandridge says she doesn't
remember exactly when she first heard
that the show was gonna be made but that
when she did she was like oh man that
would be so cool I don't remember when I
first heard about it but when I did I
was like Mommy want that but didn't
think they would actually cast her
because it was such a big show so she
thought her chances of getting cast in
place of a bigger name was slim but
thank goodness struckman called her to
offer her the role and she remembers
being in disbelief and just so so
honored and excited to get to ReDiscover
the character Dandridge also notes that
she thought she was a better fit for
Marley now than back when she played her
for the game because she had aged and
matured into the character and thus
could relate better but she was also
nervous making the transition from
motion capture performance to film not
only because the time Gap since she
played Marlene was so great but for
practical reasons too actually wearing
the clothes and getting to walk around
in the world was a whole new experience
for her down to little things like she
had never worn a wig on camera before
but the heart of the character that
Dandridge helped create really Shone
through and seeing her get to bring this
character to life again and deep in her
story was such a treat one of the more
well-known cameos was the voice and
mocap actor for Joel Troy Baker who
played James in the show baker said an
interview that he didn't actually want
to play Joel having already had the
opportunity to play him and giving it
his all then and loved the choice of
Pedro Pascal playing Jill instead he
joked he would have been happy just
being a clicker and recounts the story
of druckman approaching him to play
James and Baker being like ah dude who's
James oh right buddy boy the guy at that
time he knew the game well and knew that
James died but also knew that the show
would have the opportunity to zoom in on
certain characters and expand their
stories and thought it was a unique
opportunity for him to see this world
through a whole new set of eyes he was
thrilled at the Prospect and notes he
loves playing villains enjoying the
challenge of getting the audience to
like him even for a second so the hatred
is that much stronger when it's called
for what he didn't anticipate however
was the added difficulties that came
with doing a live-action adaptation when
the actors were mo-capping for the game
there was never any blood or anything
they just had to pretend that they were
bleeding in film it's a lot more
complicated and he remembers spending
the entire morning in Prosthetics to get
a magnetic attachment in his neck so the
cleaver would stick when Ellie swung it
at him along with going through eight
changes of wardrobe due to all a fake
blood gushing everywhere and having to
sit in a cold pool of his own blood
during takes acting ain't always
glamorous folks one of the most
appropriately symbolic cameos in The
Last of Us was Ashley Johnson playing
Anna Ellie's mom Johnson played Ellie in
the games and describes what an ammonia
emotional experience it was she said
Neil texted her that they would love her
to play Anna for a scene and she just
burst into tears I remember when Neil
texted me and I just instantly burst
into tears because I was like wait are
you serious no way since the actors for
video games usually don't transfer over
to the screen adaptation she was utterly
shocked that she would even get to play
a part druckman never intended on
leaving her out of it though since she
had been such an integral part of the
process of creating Ali and felt this
part was perfect saying she gave birth
to Ellie figuratively with the game and
here she literally does it in the show
and it truly is the perfect handoff
Ellie is a huge part of Johnson and vice
versa and to be able to reflect that in
the show's story and allow the audience
to feel the love that Johnson has for
the character is deeply meaningful and
to be the one to give birth to Ellie in
the show and also be the first character
to fight to keep Ellie alive meant a lot
to Johnson in the game there's a letter
from Anna that Ellie keeps in her
backpack and Johnson revealed that
during the show she actually wrote that
letter out and kept it in her pocket
which is just so touching it was the
Cameo no one knew they needed until it
happened so that concludes all of the
camps from the HBO show which Cameo is
personal favorite are there any you hope
to see for season two let us know below
until then you can follow me on Twitter
at it'sanavanston and follow And
subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love
ah
a
[Music]
foreign